-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
It's time to play "Password."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Our first team tonight --
she's the star
of the Netflix series "Maid,"
and her teammate
is the host of NBC's
"The Tonight Show"
and Saugerties' Sweetheart.
It's Margaret Qualley
and Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-And their opponents are
the stars of the Hulu series
"Only Murders in the Building."
It's Steve Martin
and Martin Short.
-Oh! I can't believe it.
We're on.
-That's a booking.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah.
-You didn't know you were here?
-No. Had no idea.
-That's a marquee.
-We didn't even know
we were doing a TV show.
-Wow.
-That's so funny.
-Well, the rules of the game
are very simple.
-They are?
-Yes.
I will give each of you
a password,
and then you are allowed
to give a one-word clue --
that's one word only --
to get your partner
to guess the password.
The team with the most points
after four words wins.
All right, we're gonna
start off with Jimmy and...
-Why am I so scared?
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Here we go.
-It's your natural state.
-Jimmy and Marty.
-The password is...
-Marty, why don't you start?
-Who's -- Who's --
-Martin's going to start.
Martin Short will start us off.
Martin Short will start the game
in one-word clues
to give to Steve,
as of one, two, now.
-S-Steve...
-Martin.
-Yeah. No. Hold on.
-No, that wasn't the password.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, um, electric...
-Are you allowed to do gestures?
-Sure.
-Sure. Why not. Why not.
-'Cause it's clearly
a lawn mower.
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
-Oh.
-Jimmy, go. You got it.
-Roomba.
-Vacuum.
-Whoa!
Oh, my goodness!
Margaret. Wow!
-This is a man who has never
vacuumed in his life.
You don't go like that
with a vacuum.
-Two-handed --
-That's a lawn mower.
-A two-handed vacuum.
-That was a disaster, Steve.
You're an idiot.
-The password is...
-I want a different partner!
-Margaret, you're up.
-Margaret goes first.
-Oh. Ooh.
Um...
[ Buzzes lips ]
Uh, blueberry...
[ Laughter ]
-Boy, that narrows it down.
-A lot of options there.
-All right. Blueberry...
[ All talking at once ]
-Blueberry...muffin.
-Yes!
♪♪
-Whoa!
-There was conversationing.
-What?!
-No.
-Not only did we say
blueberry muffin,
but then also, I did this,
and you grabbed me like that.
-That's partners.
That's partners.
-She was acting out a blueberry.
-Wow. Muffin.
Blueberry muffin.
-The password is...
-Jimmy, why don't you
start us off this time?
-Yeah. Okay.
Okay.
-Hmm.
-Okay.
-Tricky.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
I'm gonna say -- Oh, wow. Okay.
Um...
Whew.
[ Martin Short imitating
crickets chirping ]
-Are those crickets?
Those are crickets.
-Internet?
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
What?
-You made me nervous.
-Internet?
-Um...Wi-Fi.
-No.
-[ Buzzer ]
-By the way, I know this look.
It means something else.
-Okay.
"Only Murders in the Building."
-No, that's four words.
[ Buzzer ]
What is wrong with you?
-He's plugging his show.
He can't help it.
-Okay. "Only."
[ Laughter ]
-All right, Jimmy, you go.
You go.
-Uh...
download.
-What'd he say?
-Download.
-Ohh!
-Um, I'm thinking
we're in the world of...
-yeah, yeah, yeah.
-We need to --
-Mm-hmm. We're in that world.
-Like Blue...
-Yeah.
-...tooth. Bluetooth.
-No.
-[ Buzzer ]
-It is in that world.
It is in that world.
-Really -- Steve, Steve.
Look at me.
Focus. Ready?
-Where do you think
he was looking before?
-97 words. I'm getting an essay.
-Okay, ready?
Podcast.
[ Buzzer ]
-That is the word.
-No. That's the word.
-Oh, shoot!
-Oh. That is the word.
-I hate when that happens.
[ Laughter ]
You couldn't help yourself.
Yeah. Okay.
-What were you going to say?
-When you tell me to focus,
you got to plan.
-Margaret.
-This is the last one.
-Don't look, Marty.
-The password is...
-Steve,
you're gonna start us off.
-I got first?
-Yeah, this is worth
one billion points.
-Wow. Okay.
-That's a lot of points.
-Uh, femur.
-Leg.
[ Buzzer ]
-Cheating already.
Cheating, cheating, cheating.
-Okay.
-The cheating twins.
-We're not the cheating twins.
-Uh, duh, you are.
-So, he said femur and leg.
That's what he said.
And then I'm gonna go
a different direction
and I'm gonna say, um...
funny.
-Oh. There's only one word, man.
I'm gonna say this
on the count of three.
One, two, three.
Bone.
-Whoo!
-Wow!
A billion and 16 points!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Margaret Qualley, the champ.
Steve Martin and Martin Short.
-We got nothing. We got zero.